hot dad alert
chris cuomo just made a shirtless cameo
on his daughter bella's tick tock
account
and we are not okay it's kind of weird
to open tick tock up and see people
calling my family members hot like
that's
a weird experience seventeen-year-old
bella shared
this candid clip of her parents chris
and christina
in the bathroom yeah that's chris sans
shirt rocking shorts and six pack abs
whoa chiseled af anyway
christina looks fire too sporting a
black one-piece swimsuit
hey
[Music]
bella's caption me trying to say good
night to my parents during their 20-step
night routine but real talk can we get a
detailed step-by-step guide to that
night routine because
i'm here for whatever they're doing in
another tick tock video
bella dances to kendrick lamar's track
money trees
and her dad well he totally bombs the
whole thing
and i'm not mad at it
[Music]
those are some serious muscles guys
he's 50. i'm not gonna lie videos with
dad gave me a boost
of course this isn't the first time
chris has dropped in on his daughter's
tick tocks
back in may he showed off his moves
[Music]
okay he showed off his dad moves
at the time bella dished to e.t about
her dad's tick-tock skills
or lack thereof most of the time it's
like yeah it's like
dancing around just thinking he can sing
doing it real loud so everyone can hear
it
and her mama opened up about their
special daddy-daughter bond
bella is really the only one who can
handle her father very brilliantly
you know he loves her to death and
uh you know it's the father um
daughter relationship that you just
can't get in between
and while they might be super close
bella isn't exactly looking to follow in
the cnn
journalists footsteps for now i'm pretty
focused on
um acting and singing and i do a lot of
theater at school and i go to a theater
camp and that's
that's what i love to do and like the
dream is to love what you do every day